all right everybody let's close up the
hour with something super fun I came
across on social media this is what I'm
liking so it's not all that common that
you see people getting married at 77
years old but check out just how happy
this bride is I love it maybe it's
because doy she she married herself
she's so happy right now that's right
she said I do to a lifetime of being
with her favorite person and you know
what I say nicely done
yeah we have her on the line right now
watching on wcp o9 well doy you might be
the only person that we know for sure
you're not getting
divorced so describe your wedding I got
married in my retirement home and I had
a lot of friends and family and I my
daughter fixed everybody a nice
plate and I had a p
and uh and some flowers yeah and I was
so
excited I'm telling you have you was
soed so Donnie have you ever been
married before to not yourself had you
ever been married to anybody else yes oh
you had been I got married in a
courthouse with a black dress on in 40
years I decided I loved myself and I
wanted to do something special for
myself so I married
myself oh I love you so much thank you
Dy I'm loving your post right now and
that's not all our season long partner
pilot pin makers of G2 the go look at
this look at this oh my god oh my god
wow
I was like what are you doing how are
you I'm good are you good are you where
should I stand hell how are
you are you doing Jimmy tonight yeah are
you doing Jimmy tonight oh my God I was
like we always run into people in the
hallway I'm actually in New York City we
just announced a world tour for 30
seconds tomorrow so
we we we just were at iHeart together we
both did that show together you sounded
incredible man I cannot wait to go see
your show thank you I appreciate it it's
been six years so we just put a new
album out and now we have a new tour and
it's it's incredible oh my God I love it
I'm so stoked for yall y'all sound
incredible it was a great show I love
that you stopped by I appreciate it yeah
it's been a crazy day I climbed the
Empire State Building this morning so
I'm a little I'm a little tired what no
they think I'm joking no no did wait
what you really climbed the Empire State
Building yeah yeah I didn't even know
youat I didn't why what
was it was it was it it was it a was it
a bet it's just just to celebrate the
launch of the tour you know I've always
loved uh the Empire State building ever
since I was a kid I was fascinated by it
probably not the only one but it always
was a symbol to me of New York and of
following your dream so I thought what a
great way to launch the tour the oh my
God that's really cool you're a brave I
just you I just no I just say I'm going
on tour that's it when I do it I love it
you just swung by
You Want to Say Goodbye To America with
me we're maybe give some money away you
want to do that with me all right pleas
our season long partner pilot pin makers
of G this is incredible I love 30 Rock
You have no idea what's going to happen
the gos been of the Kelly Clarkson show
uh want to honor truly Unstoppable
people just like you dty she just
married herself congratulations Dy yes
so they're going to be riding you a
check for $1,000 as a wedding gift dnie
so you're getting
$1,000 thank you to all our guest our
jeel Sheila E Ashley flowers Harley
Michael and K Kay all a great D it's not
maybe Jared letter will pop up and make
your
[Music]
[Applause]
day thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home